you go to sever yar around you know you
take the cut the bottom of the crate out
no great get up on the on the pole yeah
you hang it up you nailed it to the see
an alley you got the wood there's a
that's like the home cable a stab at it
you another today and you play
basketball so we yeah we hooked on that
then we go to ground ramp Walmart then
we start once the parks if you could get
compared if you could compare your music
to Anthony who would it be
oh yeah
that was fast no hey I know cuz it would
like win it didn't it coming they
counted us out now we back one nothing
yeah so my destiny I just feel like that
that's the perfect perfect apparently
then we thought Chicago what can you
tell me as a Chicago native didn't want
or got no right I think was 96
you know I'm young I'm think we watching
up no they got full everything in the
house I'm taking this is a regular
basketball game
yeah so when we when they won like the
hose to Chicago just thought more crazy
new brand around hanging up the windows
but I'm like damn awful game and not
knowing that area chicks on my okay okay
they're not really I wouldn't really
know too much about sports at that age
but you were around you recognize it
yeah yeah like I wit I got this bearish
deck you know something spinners at all
experiences at all but I ask you what's
your favorite Air Jordan I like three
Brie's three which color would matter of
fact I'm laughs off a 111 never met that
perfect fit they go with anything you
put a suit on it was nice wits anything
hey three things bad either man no my
property they bad
you move a human Olympics M who could
forget classic classic but I think
people say have 11 people stick on the
eights I wasn't big fan of age growing
up little scraps of [ __ ] - one that
saintly - yeah
you gotta do the bunny ears though if
you're not doing the bunny ear do not
look oh did you play any sports
growing up like i've seen i didn't play
basketball I used to be under Jesse
white time would say you said that what
seemed Jesse White Tom wasn't saying the
tumbling team oh really you get that
click Frank all that yeah did you ever
compete well I was close we flip don't
tell it in a brave let see grace I'm
really learning it say will you see a
girl by using this as a mean what was
your reaction we started seeing [ __ ] pop
up everywhere and people put nail
captions on oh is my code like a main
like that like it's a good lima cool
name this is bad like ain't doing too
much nein trying to provide whooshes
Nessa me this is one of my favorite
means man it's just home it's all time
doing I thank you yeah
[Laughter]
this too right here this dude there's
three in here bro oh really
upstairs yeah
I got down I got down I don't have to
free him bro we got an air strike we
jumped on this three up there nothing
you Top Gear's now they're fighting
they're fighting and locatable let me
guess you can give me some and they're
gonna jump out of that roof of that
house right there you want 44